No
[Music]
the gods of Olympus have abandoned us so
now we're off to some Norse mythology
good I'm tomorrow and I'm joined by a
debut it hello we're gonna be talking
about God of War the rebooted version of
some one of Sony's biggest franchises
which is back and very different now I'm
a huge God of War fan made every single
one complete every single one except for
ascension because at the mobile one no
no no those ones were good surprisingly
it's the last ps3 one it was like it had
a multiplayer mode and it was I was like
I'm alright without this you know but
this is very different and anyone who
has a lot of experience with god of war
can immediately tell it's different in a
lot of ways we played the early from the
very beginning the first two and a half
two and a half hours and the first thing
I noticed was it doesn't open like a God
of War game God of War Games opening
quite a dramatic fashion with a set
piece or like a really strong moment
that sticks with you the first one had
the gods of Olympus have abandoned us
and chaos kill kind of kills himself
second one had the Colossus of Rhodes
where you're fighting the Colossus this
one opens we've like a solemn moment
where you're just chatting to your son
and that's a big part of this game it's
like trying to recast Kratos as a more
sympathetic character and it does that
despite doing all of these look so
simple so those are those are things
that we probably won't be able to
discuss in any major way but we can talk
about in a big way is the combat and as
you can probably tell here it's very
different the older games they were all
built around the blades of chaos which
were these kind of really long-range
weapons that you could like hit multiple
people with as though things changed to
his wrist pain to his eye I never
actually played the original gotta fall
right but you've seen enough image of
him to know how iconic those blades are
but he loses those at the end of I think
it's three this is the new axe that he
has and it's like frost based so it's
it's got a bunch of really cool
properties and the we were talking to
Cory Balrog who's the
director of this game and has directed
go to war - and written a bunch of other
ones and he actually said like God of
War was created in response to a can't
remember who it was there was a Japanese
designer of combat games it might have
been someone that planned it might have
been someone else I don't want to you
know call someone else
but they said Western developers
basically don't know how to make combat
and so they made God of War which was
like and it was hugely successful as a
fan of Japanese combat games
I wouldn't say God of War kind of came
anywhere close to what they were doing
but this on the other hand does okay
this comes way closer to being like
something that they could give to a
Japanese develop and say this is our
take on what you're doing because it has
some of the fluidity of Japanese action
games their mechanics behind those kind
of like character action games like
Bayonetta or vanquish and stuff for that
it doesn't have the Flair of it but it
kind of trades that in for a kind of a
really heavier feel a heft and this kind
of like realism I want to say but it's
not like realistic but like it feels
like that if I said I'm imagine if you
took kind of the heft in like the the
chunkiness of Gears of War and combined
it with a combat from like a platinum
game a Devil May Cry sheesh you would
expect crates to move like Bayonetta
would you know you wouldn't and what he
does in this case in some instances like
as you can tell like we're in an
exploration section here but we'll soon
see like he's got a mixture of moves
that he can use like the axis is kind of
the centerpiece of the combat so use it
as like the main melee weapon right now
but as you can see here you couldn't
throw it and then summon him back and
that's all manual like it's not
automatic you choose when to throw it
and you choose when to bring it back and
as you saw there like on the way back it
hits things and it damages things okay
so like you use that to your advantage
and just with that that one small
gameplay faster it's already got more
depth than the original god of wars
those who had different weapons and you
could use them in interesting ways
but like they all felt isolated they
never felt connected to each other when
you do something like throw your axe
while that axe is out doing its own
thing you've got your hands you've got
your fists and you've got your shield so
it's like you can hit an enemy with your
axe a few times not coming to the air
for
your ax of a distant enemy and if you
learned it in in their head it freezes
them in place cause it's a frost axe
right so they basically locked out the
fight for a while while they're locked
out you can kind of like use your fists
to do extra damage pop them back into
the air while they're in the air summon
your ex back and on the way back it'll
kind of chip them so like you've got
that and then you can do other moves as
well you unlock abilities through
upgrading and you can do things like
freeze them and knock back and stuff
like that so it becomes this kind of
really fluid combat system where you're
switching between weapons and abilities
and that kind of stuff well though we
didn't get to see like the full
potential of it from what I played in
the first two hours I felt like I was
thinking about combat in a way that I
hadn't in the previous god of war games
before it was like what's currently the
most part what's the right weapon for
this enemy and all there is some of that
now I'm able to go through weapons and
to figure out all right mid combo this
isn't working so I'm just gonna throw
this axe in that direction pin down that
enemy and use them you know my fists so
here we're fighting one of the major
mini bosses and he was featured in the
e3 trailer and that boss is a massive
behemoth and does a lot of damage and
it's all about like ducking and moving
and then getting in doing an attack and
then getting out and like shooting his
weak points to slow him down a bit and
that if you've played Dark Souls I hate
to bring up Dark Souls in every single
thing about combat is a thing that you
will sound familiar for your cosplayers
and that feeds back into the combat
itself so when we were talking to Corey
he was like I can tell the kind of game
you like based on the way you play our
game and interact with our combat which
was really fascinating to me so like he
told me I know you like platinum games
and he's right I love like you know
planning's games I love this the the
clover stuff I love you know c'mere and
all the stuff that did hurt Devil May
Cry and Boehner and vanquish and all
that kind of business and he was able to
tell that without me telling him based
on the way I played because I was doing
loads of combat so I was aiming for
combat I was doing loads of combats so
much combat
I was doing loads of combos and like
popping into the air and trying to like
manage enemies and always moving and
like dashing towards enemy and he was
able to tell that and looking around the
room he could also figure out who like
Dark Souls because other players were
kind of like
so chillin yeah kind of approaching the
enemy like locking on doing the circle
strafing and then finding an opening and
getting in doing a big amount of damage
and in getting out right so like this
Stiles
so that just sees that there's enough
depth and enough like open-endedness in
this combat system to kind of
accommodate a bunch of styles which is
really fascinating to me it's completely
the opposite of the way God of War felt
before
it's always been an enjoyable combat
experience but I wouldn't describe it as
deep and deep and really like creative
it just doesn't reward you for being
like figuring out the nuances and trying
to implement them so you can see Hays
frozen the frost axe and then punch him
at the other enemy and that's really
important so the original god of war
games yeah is it looks sick first of all
like it is really that's one thing it
hasn't lost God of War was always about
like a pet it was always a power trip
right and this game is going for
something different now it wants to
humanize Kratos it's got his Sunday at
Reyes you can see chilling out in the
background firing arrows and you're he
actually does what he wants hmm it's
controlled by AI but he works into your
combat so if you you have he's assigned
to a button on your controller and all
it does is he fires an arrow and
basically what that does is it draws
aggro for you okay and you can try to
point him as well using your own aiming
reticule and he'll fire where your
reticule is so insult on some enemies
you can aim for weak points but his most
you know important uses drawing aggro so
he'll pull an enemy away from you
in the early game we're only fighting
like variations of Drago's here are
these kind of zombie like creatures from
Norse mythology and for the most part
they were all pulled by him but I'm not
sure how it works if there's like a
really powerful enemy and you're trying
to get him off you he'd probably ignore
at Reyes but you need to do that and you
need to constantly be moving because of
all the all the games that kind of just
gave you a bunch of enemies to fight it
almost felt like here's a here's a room
almost felt like Dynasty Warriors in a
certain way like they always had
different styles and they always in
different beliefs but you were there
just to stomp them right and feel good
while stomping them the enemies in these
encounters they feel more placed and
they feel more like designed in a
certain way and like they've chosen
hand-picked so that they can present you
specific challenges and try and
encourage you to play in certain ways
and figure out the ins and outs of
combat and you really have to spend a
lot of time thinking about how you crowd
control and who you prioritize and you
do that using abilities like throwing
your axe and freezing someone in place
using a trace to draw attention and like
if it's like really key because you you
also have like a quick turn button which
is something that you usually only see
in Resident Evil yes because you really
need to quickly be able to snap around
and address something like a long-range
enemy firing at you for example in like
that is like we're seeing right here and
obviously crows is a larger-than-life
character and you're obviously making
him look very good right now but is he
is he actually quite it like would an
enemy be able to easily Downing's it
sounds like you with all these abilities
to keep crowd control sounds like he's
constantly under threat yeah so the way
they like kratos like you said is is a
big that he's killed gods at this yeah
and so like he shouldn't be able to be
down by a dragger they can down you and
the kill can kill you but the way they
do is often by whittling you down in big
numbers which is another reason why
these encounters are so like over the
top they manage to somehow have loads of
enemies but without falling into the
trap of just having let's throw these
enemies and beat honestly or is they
like think about how many you know how
many enemies there are and there's
usually a lot of them and also make sure
that their different variety and the
challenging and in specific ways but
yeah but like the the brutality of
Kratos is still there although they're
kind of like that that's one part of him
that fans always loved like he was
unrelenting he'd everything he did came
with a grunt and a groan and it's like
you know you've the ripple of muscles
everything from like opening doors to
opening chests and that still him and
like every when he lifts up you know
stone doors you can hear him you can
actually see some of his back muscles
rippling it so if you're like well into
chaos his muscles you will see them
another thing that you saw there was the
kid was kind of looking at some runes
and that plays into the story here
Kratos is a Greek character almost Greek
mythology character so he his boys were
like the Zeus and the lads
they're all dead now because he's killed
them yeah so now he's in like this Norse
realm he shouldn't be there and
we're not quite sure why he's there yet
and although I won't spoil some of the
stuff that happens that we saw there's
some questions from other people of
Norse mythology about why he's there as
well but he's completely disconnected
from the culture like he doesn't
understand anything he can't read those
rooms he doesn't understand much about
the culture of normal north culture and
he gets all that through his son so his
son obviously he had another wife in the
previous games he had a child but they
were lost because he killed them hmm
spoilers for spoilers for the game like
if teens yeah yeah so that was kind of
like the thing that was tormenting him
and what led him on his mad blood rage
rampage but now you know he's had
another family and the son he he and his
son are on like a journey right now they
don't like a not a Vision Quest but
they're basically doing something
they're just trying to reach the top of
the mountain right and along that way
he's kind of trying to help his son grow
as a person and also himself cuz he's a
bad father but he's trying like he knows
he has to try and he knows that he needs
to be better and in return like the Sun
is trying to help connect him to the
world around Kratos to the world around
him so whenever you see things like
runes and stuff like that cRIO says all
you can do is like what does it say and
the kid figures it out and like is able
to tell you and that's an interesting
way of making a character like a
secondary character important to you and
feel meaningful so we have this thing in
video games where companion characters
often feel like they are knowing and
wasted but then we have certain
characters like you know Joel and Ellie
those a good pairing and I think Sony
Santa Monica and the god god award him
have looked at lost of us quite a lot
obviously you know Noah dog is assists
the studio to them almost and that you
can see they've drawn clear inspiration
from them he's not only kind of like his
you know path to learning about the
world but it's also like for the player
it's how you learn the story and how you
learn about Norse mythology as well and
I suppose one of the ways to take a
character that's so large like Kratos
who's killed gods one of the few ways
that you can take him out of his comfort
zone is to put in an environment that's
so alien to him yeah so that that is
really fascinating because it's it
speaks to like a new
that wasn't there in previously like its
Kratos was so focused on just killing
things that you never got to really
experience Greek called not culture but
like the Greek mythology in any
meaningful way because you're too busy
just destroying it put in Zeus is jewel
you're just like doing crazy stuff so
this game is more about exploration and
it rewards you for for learning about
the world like it's taking I'm not
saying it's taking inspiration but it
comes after like the the learnings we
have about and like the kind of trend of
people wanting to be in the worlds and
be absorbed by those worlds like
Assassin's Creed and world and various
other games you know and you know even
lost of us you want to see more of that
world and it's only Santa Monica clearly
in touch with that and I'm making sure
you can do that so you can go around
this like branching paths now areas for
you to kind of like explore and at the
end of them like that you find like oh
there's a nice like painting here kratos
will just look at it and it looks like a
painting but then at Reyes would jump up
and be like oh this is the this legend
about this god who ate the Sun and his
brother who ate the moon and they became
wolves and etc except he'll break it
down for you and that's really really
cool unfastening and like it's a really
cool way to bring kratos like make
create us feel more meaningful and
grounded in a world without kind of
taking away that was the kind of hero
style of him you know being this massive
hulking madman and he's just trying to
destroy everything and kill everything
but yeah it's it's a really fascinating
more surprised about I'm way more
confident in it now than I was
previously you know like the idea of
bringing chaos back I wasn't totally
against it but like I I had faith in
Corey and that team and now that I've
played it I feel a little more confident
about it I feel good about the combat I
hope that it develops in a more you know
it adds depth to it right now it's
looking real good you've got I've got a
lot of tools and I can normally thinking
about when I left I felt I wanted to
play the demo again but yeah wouldn't
allow me because I felt more confident
at the end of it with everything that I
had and like there's still things that I
wasn't able to explore like one of them
is the we saw briefly earlier the the
crafting and kind of upgrade system
which is new like the you in the
previous game you were just given things
yeah you do
you puzzles which there are loads of
puzzles in this game as well and your
reward for doing those puzzles would be
a new bit of gear in this you have that
merchants who will help upgrade your
stuff and you can build stuff and it's
reflected on your character model which
is also new you know before you'd have
equipment and you'd only see the
equipment when you used it and it would
like come out this magic bomb the sack
he probably had on him and it would just
appear and then you'll vanish again
whereas now your character model changes
as you equip new weapons but I'm so it's
probably freezing there he's always at
his top off me he doesn't need clothes
you're he oh yeah
but yeah I'm very I was very pleasantly
surprised and as like it's shut up my
most anticipated list for this year in a
significant way and that's not me just
like you know kissing butts here like I
don't do that stuff I'm really genuinely
super excited about this and it's like
pushed a whole bunch of other
high-profile games out the way and yeah
I'm really eager to play more it's
coming out in on April 20th so we don't
have money for 20 destroy it
hold sweaty smash it with an axe well
you sold me on the game like I said I've
never I've never played God of War I
think you're really gonna like it yeah
yeah I think you're right because you're
a massive dork and different kind of
fancy and you like Norse mythology as
well I know I'm probably gonna like
crank up the immigrant song a little any
entire game yeah and it's and it's
really really like they've clearly paid
attention and they've got like language
experts in to kind of decipher all this
noise runes and put together their own
kind of like take on it and they've done
the legwork to make it an interesting
world so yeah and it plays really well
so I think you really really like it if
this is November God of War yeah I think
it's a really good entry point and I
think most people if it manages to land
what it does they might come away
thinking oh man I need to go back and
play those so that's what I thought of
God aboard the reboot very excited for
it if you'd like to see more of the game
keep your eyes on gamespot comm you can
also visit our youtube page youtube go
comment or slash games what what do you
know it where we have more of this game
got trailers we've got a feature with
Corey Barlow coming up it's an interview
which is kind of Airy interesting so you
should keep your eyes out for that and
we rank
game dad's he's I think I need to see
where guys for he's pushing up he's
getting to the top I think Reyes is dad
yeah he is dead yet like he's daddy
goals like if you were that you want to
be as ripped as he is I mean you're not
wrong yeah and have a cool axe that you
can summon at any point imagine if your
kid will run yeah imagine if your kid
was acting out and just an ax appear in
your head every time in the meantime you
can find us on Twitter I'm at two more
hey and I'm a regular Dave and we will
see you soon
you